in this video we present experis cope
our tool for analyzing the experimental
results gathered when comparing or
evaluating interaction techniques to use
our tool one needs to gather the logs of
events such as mouse clicks mouse
movements and key presses that were
recorded during an experiment upon
reading the experimental logs Xperia
vada matically clusters each interaction
pattern for example the experiment here
is considering two types of tasks
repetition and alternation for modal
techniques persists spring once once and
springboard and to command selection
techniques Lagoon and marking inside
each experimental cell the tool further
clusters interaction patterns by
separating correct scenarios from those
that triggered errors identical
interaction sequences are then
aggregated as one pattern interaction
patterns that occurred less than five
percent of the time are grouped as in
frequent interactions within an
aggregation experis cope additionally
clusters individual trials by user ID
the patterns in an aggregation with
durations larger than three standard
deviations from the mean are grouped as
outliers double clicking on any
given pattern opens the visualization
window for this pattern the
visualization represents activity both
from the dominant hand on top and the
non-dominant hand on the bottom in this
example the maroon color represents a
pen device and the blue color represents
a command key on the keyboard our
notation also includes a set of symbols
reflecting key events here you can see
icons indicating when the user marks a
command labels may be included to
indicate system events in this example
there are flags indicating when a menu
is displayed users can also add their
own annotations here we add a label to
indicate where a user draws a circle by
using the inking command our tool also
offers several features to help compare
participant behavior in varied settings
to compare one pattern to another simply
drag and drop the new technique onto an
existing visualization as you can see
our tool highlights the relative
differences in speed using gray
trapezoidal patterns here the pattern on
top begins around the same time as the
pattern below but then the bottom
technique slows down after the first
dominant hand interaction
you
as another feature to easily identify
interesting patterns experis cope allows
patterns to be sorted by frequency
duration and standard deviation it is
also the case that to interactions may
have different patterns while they are
essentially similar in such cases
researchers can create new clusters on
the fly through a simple drag-and-drop
operation the tool represents the
disagreement within a sequence of events
by using a hatching pattern the average
between two interactions is computed in
the areas where patterns agree
experience cope also provides an
alignment feature
first we create a reference point on one
technique and then we align other
diagrams to this point this feature
makes it easy to compare sub patterns of
interactions within a more general
pattern because of these features
experis coat makes it possible to
efficiently determine the areas of
interest within a command selection
experiment giving the researcher insight
about the underlying reasons for
specific experimental results as well as
a diversity of user behavior